et figurez-vous que c'est pas si
déconnant que ça par rapport au prix de
ce produit sur la France entière c'est
un produit plutôt de qualité c'est une
marque qui s'appelle paysan breton vous
l'avez flouté mais ce qui la connaissent
là la reconnaissance
[Rires]
non plus sérieusement le prix moyen de
ce produit aujourd'hui dans tous les
magasins français pas uniquement dans
celui-là c'est 6,28 € vous voyez vous
étiez quand même loin tout à l'heure
quand vous donniez le prix du beurre
c'est que le beurre en général a subi
une inflation de dingue ce produit là il
est aujourd'hui 30% plus cher 29
exactement qu'il y a un an à la même
date là c'est quoi c'est 500 g ou 25500
grammes c'est une plaquette de 500 g
donc ça fait quand même 15 euros le kilo
ce qui pour du beurre quand on le
présente comme ça et vachement cher mais
l'explication c'est que les paysans sont
eux-mêmes plus payés aujourd'hui qu'il
ne l'était il y a un an donc il faut
aussi savoir le prix du lait payé à
l'éleveur il est passé en gros pour
faire simple de 420 € les 1000 litres ça
fait 42 centimes le litre à peu près 500
euros voilà donc ça fait une hausse d'à
peu près aller un petit 20% donc si on
le paye plus cher c'est aussi parce que
l'éleveur est mieux payé
il faut savoir si les citoyens que nous
sommes parce que on le dit souvent on
veulent que les paysans vivent mieux il
faut bien que on accepte de payer plus
cher alors là il est passé le prix du
beurre il a explosé je vais vous dire en
mars 2022 le prix moyen du beurre
1175 le kilo le kilo bien sûr
juin 2022 13 52
septembre 2022 13 bah encore très 52
pareil
décembre 2002 15 16 et février 15,81 et
ça moi
[Rires]
bonsoir J'ai une question vous avez dit
qu'effectivement et c'est une bonne
nouvelle pour les agriculteurs il y a
une part de d'augmentation qui est indu
parce que ils ont plus d'argent on leur
donne plus d'argent mais dans le prix
global comme comment il a répartition en
gros pour faire simple sur
l'augmentation que vous voyez ici parce
que ce même produit il était à peu près
30 % moins cher l'année dernière il y a
10 ans pour faire simple 20% de plus
liés à la matière première bonne
nouvelle et 10% qui sont liés à ce qu'on
va appeler les coûts industriels la
fameuse énergie parce que pour faire du
beurre vous savez comment on fait du
beurre on fait tourner du lait pour
faire simple il faut de l'énergie après
il faut le transporter les salaires même
si on considère peut-être qu'on n'est
jamais assez payé il se trouve que les
salles oui ça que les salaires ont quand
même progressé l'année dernière donc en
réalité ce que l'on subit là quand on
fait le course c'est ni plus ni moins
qu'une somme de conséquences voilà alors
ceux qui sont le plus impactés aussi
sont les boulangers les pâtissiers
forcément parce que quand vous faites de
la pâte feuilletée vous mettez
énormément de beurre alors par contre si
vous me permettez de vous donner un truc
et notamment à ceux qui nous suivent ce
produit là je vais vous indiquer où vous
pouvez le trouver moins cher en France
j'ai regardé ça c'est alors déjà je vous
dire en absorbe tous les jours
mais au moins ce qui habiterait pas loin
nous serons c'est une société d'études
qui s'appelle A3 distrib si ton là parce
qu'elle m'a fait l'étude pour vous ce
soir qui aspire le prix de tous les prix
de tous les magasins tous les jours en
permanence et donc je peux vous dire que
ce produit là le moins cher écoutez bien
il est à 4 € 76 Auchan de noyau c'est
dans l'Oise donc c'est pas si loin que
ça c'est combien
si tu en mets plein le coffre tu peux
peut-être signer le voyage si tu habites
à Paris mais va dire ça au mec qui
habite à toi voilà non mais plus
sérieusement vous voyez il y a de très
grands écarts alors s'il est à Marseille
parce que on sait tout sur tout il ira
mais c'est vrai à Marignane au
Chronodrive il Opera 4,47 par contre
attention il y a que 5 jours de date
donc il faudra qu'il le consomme
rapidement vous voyez le niveau de
fleurs qu'on peut avoir
ben je t'enverrai tout à l'heure c'est
accessible on consommateur ce que vous
avez comme info là parce que c'est
génial non c'est une info qui est
accessible mais malgré tout juste pour
vous dire qu'il y a une transparence
totale sur les prix et que en réalité
moi j'ai pu vous dire où était le
magasin c'est du simple au double est-ce
que la date de péremption elle est très
proche parce qu'il y en a un qui a pas
fait son métier sur la répercussion des
prix en gros le Auchan en question il
perd de l'argent quand il vend il le
sait pas mais là maintenant que je
voulais dire il va rétablir le prix
demain matin donc si vous voulez y aller
c'est à 8h30 c'est pas après ouais c'est
sûr parce que c'est pas possible alors
les les regarder il y a des produits qui
ont le plus augmenté 60 millions de
consommateurs a fait le bilan des
produits qui ont plus augmentés regardez
ce gestes
pas échappé votre panier de course est
de
plus en tête 60 millions de
consommateurs à établi un podium de
l'inflation en tête ce paquet de sucre
plus 100 euros et 5 centimes 2 ans près
de 4 euros d'augmentation pour ses
steaks hachés et 32 centimes de plus
pour ses pattes c'est hausse touche
l'alimentaire mais aussi les produits
d'hygiène l'auteur de l'enquête le
constate l'augmentation des prises s'est
accélérée l'année dernière et devrait
continuer jusqu'à l'été et
malheureusement la baisse que tout le
monde attend elle n'aura pas lieu cette
année il faudra s'habituer pendant toute
l'année 2023 à des prix très très élevés
beaucoup trop élevés pour le pouvoir
d'achat de la plupart des consommateurs
alors je le trouve un peu pessimiste
parce que je vais vous donner une raison
d'espérer que malgré tout à partir de
l'été ça puisse être mieux il suffit de
regarder le cours du blé qui est
aujourd'hui plus bas qu'il ne l'était au
moment du déclenchement de la guerre à
l'Ukraine l'année dernière ça veut pas
dire que les biscuits vont baisser
demain parce qu'il y a toujours un temps
de latence vous savez que le blé c'est
un produit qui s'achète des moins à
l'avance mais malgré tout ça finira par
se répercuter donc on peut quand même
espérer avant la fin de l'année mais on
parle tout le temps de l'inflation de la
guerre en Ukraine de l'énergie et que
les entreprises n'ont pas le choix mais
est-ce qu'en vrai il y a des marques qui
en profite et qui se gave bien sûr on va
totalement transparent il y a toujours
ce qu'on appelle des passagers
clandestins de l'inflation toujours
parce que parce que c'est l'opportunisme
qui guide pour une part économie donc
celui qui est en retard sur ses marges
et qui se dit tiens j'ai pas réussi
l'année dernière à passer mes hausse de
prix il va être tenté de se dire tiens
j'ai un bon argument pour la passer
cette année mais malgré tout si on doit
faire aller une côte mal taillée 80 à
90% de l'inflation que l'on subit nous
les consommateurs elle est lég mais j'ai
pas dit 100% parce que oui il y a des
passagers clandestins toujours bien sûr
il y a une étude qui on n'arrête pas de
dire que les plus démunis vont à cause
de l'inflation renoncer à certains
produits et notamment les produits
d'hygiène c'est assez désastreux c'est à
dire que ces gens-là non seulement vont
être allés vont aller sur des produits
de premier premier prix et en plus vont
devoir renoncer et ont déjà commencé à
renoncer du shampoing du gel douche
comme ça des des produits pour la viande
rouge parce que bien ce produit sur
lequel on peut renoncer un français un
Français sur deux a baissé sa
consommation c'est 51% pour être précis
c'est une étude Alix partenaire qui est
sortie aujourd'hui que j'ai relayé
d'ailleurs
51 plus démunis bien sûr et on peut même
dire trois fois pénalisés puisqu'il se
trouve que ce sont les premiers prix qui
sont le plus inflationniste parce que la
part de matières premières dans leur
prix total est plus importante vous
voyez ça fait un peu la triple peine en
plus ils prennent des des produits de
substitution par exemple de la margarine
plutôt que du beurre ou des produits
moins avec des produits voilà qui sont
moins qualitatifs quand vous achetez par
exemple une confiture premier prix vous
n'achetez pas des fruits et du sucre
vous achetez des fruits et du sirop de
glucose fructose et interroger tous les
nutritionnistes il y en a pas un qui
vous dit beaucoup de bien sur le sirop
de glucose fructose donc malheureusement
vous voyez quand vous achetez moins cher
alors par contre tous les produits bruts
quand vous achetez du fromage blanc du
beurre premier prix vous pouvez y aller
parce qu'il y a un une seule matière
première dedans c'est dès lors que vous
avez plusieurs matières premières que la
tentation de baisser la carte est forte
quand vous achetez par exemple de la
glace de la glace en bas vous savez pour
faire des boules de glace vous pouvez
acheter de la glace qui est faite avec
de la crème fraîche vers de la matière
grasse laitière ça va être très onctuant
bouche ou alors avec de l'huile végétale
parce que ça coûte moins cher alors
présenté comme ça Benjamin ça fait un
peu cracra mais malgré tout c'est ça la
réalité c'est on peut faire de la glace
avec de l'huile voilà il faut de la
matière grasse
c'est acheter des produits non
transformés
manger les choses comme ça quoi riz
complet des choses comme ça
être opportuniste sur les promotions moi
je prône ce que j'appelle l'infidélité
commerciale regardez les prospectus
Guillaume j'ai bien dit commercial
regardez les prospectus il y a des
bonnes affaires chez tout le monde il
suffit de picorer dedans et ceux qui ne
savent pas comment faire il y a des
applications aujourd'hui qui consolides
dans une belle application tous
les protons de vous
comme ça
une application qui marche comme le
tinder c'est le tinder de la promo ça
s'appelle bonial vous dites enfin vous
ouvrez votre application il sait où vous
êtes automatiquement il va vous dire
autour de moi voilà les prospectus
il y a la côte de porc qui est à 3,50 €
ici il y a le bas le temps d'aller faire
d'aller acheter la viande soir
c'est pour les familles nombreuses c'est
extrêmement compliqué
commerciale j'ai une question importante
on parle souvent de la date de
péremption on peut aller au-delà combien
de temps on va dire
sans moi après vous risquez mais alors à
rien
qui m'a dit que ça pique pas comme ça
pique pas tu resteras mettez-moi au défi
un mois passé je vais le manger devant
vous pourquoi parce que c'est des
produits qui sont stabilisés la viande
surtout pas malheureux parce qu'il y a
un réflexe qu'il faut avoir vous ouvrez
vous sentez si ça pue on a tous un nez
c'est ce qu'on fait
la règle d'or
vous pouvez même dépasser dans l'absolu
des années c'est un produit qui est
totalement stabilisé il ne cancer
d'accord stérilisé et lâcher sur
attendez parce que
j'ai dit oui sur terrestre
une connerie ce mec c'est un truc de fou
on peut faire une émission oui on peut
faire une émission
moi au début à chaque fois que j'allais
Monoprix la fille de me dire est-ce que
vous avez vous voulez une carte Monoprix
vous le garde Monoprix ouais non non ça
me saoule bon je l'ai fait à chaque fois
j'ai 10 % sur mon caddie 10% de mon
caddie avec ce que tu as pris
l'abonnement c'est pas pareil alors là
il a pris quelque chose
déconner c'est-à-dire qu'on a pas
automatiquement 10% de réduction chez
Monoprix
un abonnement qui lui coûte 9,90
donc 9,90 € par mois
à 10% de remise sur l'ensemble de votre
chariot par contre 200 €, ça fait 20 je
gagne 50 € par mois tout le temps
non non tout le temps aussi
avoir une réduction c'est quoi Amazon
Prime voilà quand tu es Amazon Prime tu
as droit d'être livré tout le temps
gratos déjà faire ses courses au
Monoprix pendant les moyens
elle a raison elle a raison si je vous
suis si je vous suis il faut donner
combien par mois
si j'y vais et que je fais des caddie
pour plein de gens et que je fais des
Cadix pour 600 euros ça ira donc j'ai 63
par contre
il y a un business enfin business
il n'y a pas de carte Lidl monsieur
et c'est ça à savoir est-ce que dans les
magasins les moins chers que Monoprix
ils font ce système d'abonnement alors
je suis quasiment mais c'est pas
franchement moins cher que Monoprix mais
non si vous prenez Lidl par exemple il
n'y a pas d'abonnement mais Lidl est
factuellement moins cher que les autres
c'est pas leur faire de la publicité
c'est une réalité les études le montre
les marques de disques sont toujours
plus intéressantes au point du prix ou
pas
99% des cas il marque de distributeur et
les moins chers pourquoi parce que dans
le prix du produit vous ne payez pas le
marketing et le commercial vous payez
que la matière première on fait pas de
pub il y a des bons produits aussi
mais ma mec moi Patrick bourrembour
bonjour un pote à moi qui est dans le
dans l'altruisme c'est vrai c'est les
courses pour tout le monde il va chez
Lidl c'est l'enseigne aujourd'hui qui
progresse le plus rapidement
l'inflation l'idole lui dit merci pour
paraphraser un slogan connu les
Mousquetaires moi je vais chez les
Mousquetaires Intermarché aussi ce n'est
pas dans quel magasin parce que pour le
coup c'est pas un seul propriétaire
c'est chaque magasin va être alors tu
sais pas tu bouges un peu c'est quand
même un supermarché je demande le
propriétaire c'est parce que connard et
vous allez avoir un vrai plaisir corail
il y a quelque chose courage
j'allais sur noyau en mouche exactement
sur la tête de ma mère c'est vrai
moi tu sais pas cher sur la Torah
bien sûr vous en fait c'est pas cher sur
la chorale
en fait la pub c'est ça je vois un
produit je fais oh waouh le beurre à
2,50 € et un Game fait et oh tu es sûr
de 0,50 je dis bien sûr frère il me dit
mais c'est pas cher sur la Cora j'ai dit
bien sûr c'est chez Cora
en fait on peut vous faire croire
en plus